Okay,
so people are possessed by a question.
It's part of our nature to be possessed
by this question and so you can think
about this as an architectural question
if you like,
and the question is what are we doing
here?
And you can ask yourself that in
relationship to this conference.
You're here to search for meaning and to
understand what that might mean,
but you also might ask yourself,
well,
why is it that you have to be here for
your search for meaning?
Why is that something that drives human
beings?
It doesn't characteristic.
For example,
of animals,
they don't seem to question their
existence,
so there's something about the very
nature of human being that makes us feel
as if something needs to be set right.
When that's been discussed historically,
it's been associated with the term
redemption.
People are in need of redemption in the
modern age.
We talk about positive psychology and we
talk about happiness,
which is a much weaker word,
but our forefathers had a more profound
sense of the problematic state of human
existence and they use more profound
words and the idea that we have a need
for redemption is a more profound idea.
Human beings,
and I'm going to talk mostly about human
beings in the West because that's the
literature that I'm most familiar with.
Human beings in the West have been
meditating on the nature of human beings
for thousands of years perhaps ever
since we became self conscious,
which is another thing that
distinguishes us from animals and
another thing that drives our search for
meaning.
The consequence of this meditation or
one of the consequences of this
meditation has been the production of a
series of books that people know is the
Bible.
I realized years ago that people saw the
world through lenses of belief and more
recently it's been demonstrated that
that's actually inevitable because
you're a limited cognitive processor.
You have to frame your perceptions with
beliefs.
What I learned is that the belief
systems that people use to frame their
perceptions have a structure and that
structure is religious,
so religious presupposition is one that
you you might even know not noticed that
you make.
It's it's a predicate or an axiom or an
assumption,
and the study of those axiomatic
assumptions is what religion is about
and one of your axiomatic assumptions,
for example,
is that life involves a search for
meaning and that's associated with the
idea of redemption and you.
You'll notice that you asked that
question because of course you're here,
but you might not notice how strange it
is that all of you asked that question
and the fact that all of you asked that
question that human beings have asked
that question for as far back as we can
understand,
is indicative of something profound
about human nature.
It's lack of completion.
I'm going to walk you through the series
of stories that make up this library of
books known as the Bible because it
presents a theory of redemption.
That in a sense is emergent.
It's a consequence of this insanely
complicated,
cross-generational meditation on the
nature of being.
It's not designed by any one person.
It's designed by processes that we don't
really understand because we don't know
anything about how books are written
over thousands of years or what forces
caused them to be compiled into a
certain way or what narrative direction
they tend to take.
Now,
one of the things that's strange about
the Bible,
given that it's a collection of books,
is that it actually has a narrative
structure.
It has a story and that story's been
cobbled together.
It's,
it's like it's emerged out of the
depths.
It's not a top down story.
It's a bottom up story.
Then I suppose that's why many of the
world's major religions regard the Bible
as a book that was revealed rather than
one that was written.
It's a perfectly reasonable
presupposition that it's revealed
because it's not the consequence of the
work of anyone author.
It's not written according to a plan or
not a plan that we can understand,
but nonetheless it has a structure.
It also has a strange structure in that
it's full of stories that no one can
forgive,
but that also that no one can understand
and the combination of incomprehensible
and unforgettable is a very strange
combination and of course that
combination is basically mythological,
so I'm going to start out by telling you
what genesis has to say about why it is
that you need to search for meaning.
Nope.
People are pretty familiar as a general
rule with the basic stories in genesis.
Genesis starts out with the word of God
creating being from chaos.
That's a very complicated idea.
The idea is that whatever the word is,
which is logos from a,
from a Christian perspective,
from a Western perspective,
that logos,
which is something like consciousness
and something like speech,
has the power to pull order out of an
underlying chaos.
Now we do this all the time.
People do this all the time.
That's I suppose in some sense,
white were hypothetically made in the
image of God.
We use our consciousness to constantly
construct being out of chaos and
according to the initial opening of
genesis.
There's something about that that's akin
to the construction of the world,
and so that means that from the
perspective of this book,
consciousness itself plays a world
constructing role.
It's got a central place and human
beings in some sense,
parties participate in that in some
minor sense I suppose,
but in a sense that not nonetheless
makes them akin to what the library
books called the Bible assumes his daddy
and one squad
logos extracts order out of chaos.
He builds a little world and it
populates it,
and then in the little world he puts a
garden,
a walled garden,
Paradise.
It's paradise means walled garden or
Eden.
Eden means well watered place and you
might think,
well,
why had garden?
And the answer to that is a garden is
the optimal combination of nature and
culture or chaos and order because the
garden is where nature flourishes,
but it's also where nature flourishes in
a,
in a safe and controlled environment.
And so that's like an optimal
environment for people and so there's a
garden.
God puts the people in there and that's
optimal.
When he warns them,
he says,
this is a strange thing.
He says,
well,
now you're in the garden.
That's where you should live and there's
something you shouldn't do and what you
shouldn't do is eat a particular fruit.
Now I'm going to tell you something
about vision.
Human beings have excellent vision.
First of all,
we see color,
hardly any creature see color,
but we do and not only do we see color,
but our vision is tremendously acute.
The only other animals that can see as
well as us or birds of prey for mammals,
man,
we can see like you wouldn't believe and
and for primates as well as we can see
much better than our closest primate
relatives and why that is is a bit of
mystery,
but there's a woman in California who
seems perhaps to absolve that her name
is Lynne Isbell and she was very
interested in how human beings develop
vision and she's interested in patterns
of Predation Predator prey
relationships,
and she knew that our treed dwelling
ancestors millions of years ago,
were frequently preyed upon by snakes.
In fact,
there's some evidence that are tree
dwelling ancestors and snakes,
coal evolved,
and that our visual system is
particularly good at picking up the
patterns of camouflage that snakes used
to hide in trees or in the undergrowth,
and what Isabelle showed was that if you
looked at primate populations around the
world where there were more predatory
snakes,
the primates could see better.
It's a very high correlation,
and so she concluded that the reason
that human beings can see so well is
because of snakes.
Now she thought the association between
that and the snake story in genesis was
interestingly coincidental,
but it's much more than that.
No,
we don't know how the Adam and Eve story
came about.
We know it's very ancient,
but there's something about it that
sticks in our memory and in our culture,
and the reason for that seems to be that
in some strange way,
it's an extraordinarily accurate
summation.
Snakes gave us vision.
What about fruit?
Lot of the reason we can see colors is
because our visual system evolved to
detect ripe fruit.
What about women?
Well,
you have to be pretty waked out a woman,
so there's this weird interconnection in
genesis between women,
fruit and snakes,
and the idea is that the interplay
between the three you remember women are
gatherers to or were gatherers
historically speaking and they shared
food with men and that's a strange thing
because human beings share food and
hardly any other animals do and so women
didn't tempt men with fruit and they
didn't make them self conscious along
with the snake and the fruit,
and that was a catastrophe.
What happens in genesis is that when
people become self conscious,
when they eat the fruit,
their vision improves.
The scales fall from their eyes and all
of a sudden they can see in a way that
no other animal has ever seen and one of
the things they can see is that they're
naked and that's a big problem.
And you might ask,
well,
what does being naked?
Meaning?
That's quite straightforward.
People often dream,
for example,
of being naked in front of a crowd and
to be naked in front of a crowd is to
have all your frailties and
vulnerabilities revealed to judgment.
And that's a nightmare for people and so
to become self aware is to wake up into
a nightmare and the nightmare involves a
profound realization,
no individual vulnerability and the
consequence of that in genesis is that
people are banished from paradise and
are from then on in need of redemption
and that they have to work and that's
how man comes to be in a fallen state
and you don't have a need for redemption
or need for meaning or request after
meaning unless you're in a fallen state
and everyone is strangely enough,
has this intuition that they're in a
fallen state,
that something is wrong with the world
that needs to be put right and and more
that or something is wrong with being.
It needs to be put right.
And more than that,
that in some weird sense,
weird way.
They have a moral obligation to
participate in that process and that
drives us like it's beneath what drives
us.
It's an axiomatic presupposition.
The next thing that happens in genesis
is that Abel and Cain are born and
they're really the first two human
beings because
Adam and eve are made by God.
Whereas Cain and Abel are born there,
they're the first people that are born
in history
and
interestingly enough,
what happens between Cain and Abel,
which is jealous,
resentment against God,
followed by murder,
is the first pattern of behavior that
human beings manifest.
Once they become self conscious.
That's an awful story and it's a
prototypical story in a sense because
what it says is that there are two
patterns of reaction to tragic
selfconsciousness and one is associated
with a murderer,
a state of resentment,
resentment towards life.
The kind of murderous resentment that
drove the killer in Colorado,
for example,
murderous resentment against life and
the other typified by Abel has something
to do with the establishment of the
antithesis of murderous resentment.
So you can associate murderous
resentment in a sense with hell and you
can associate ables path his choices
with heaven.
And so what happens is that as soon as
people become self conscious,
being divides into a domain that has
held on one on one end and heaven on
another,
and that's when we hinted that in the
second story in genesis.
After that,
everything dissolves into a flood.
That's Noah.
Into a flood,
nature comes in,
tears,
everything down and the Tower of Babel
is erected and that's a meditation on
pride.
People build a structure that's reaches
up to where God is.
It's a presumptuous act and there's
there's a reason for that too.
One of the consistent warnings that
emerges in the biblical writings,
his warnings against the sin of pride
and the sin of pride is an intellectual
sin and it's associated with the
presupposition that you know enough to
do without the transcendent and the
biblical story state very,
very clearly continually that that is
catastrophic,
dangerous,
that you always have to be aware that
there's something transcendent that
supersedes the domain of your knowledge
and and
and what,
what might you think of people who,
who don't believe that well are
totalitarians because they believed that
their belief is total and we know what
happens when people become totalitarian.
What happens is you get the instant
creation of something on earth that very
closely resembles hell and that was
hammered home in the 20th century.
If you want to derive one lesson from
the 20th century,
it's the totalitarian states and
totalitarian ideologies are not a good
way to entrap or or search after
meaning.
That's a mistake
after the flood.
The flood is before the flood.
That's prehistory.
That's so far back in time.
We can't even imagine it after the
flood.
There's A.
There's a new beginning in a sense,
and that's when history really starts
from a biblical perspective and the way
the Old Testament lays itself out then
is that it's kind of a classic hero
myth,
a hero myth.
It's associated with the establishment
of states and generally speaking,
when when societies mythologize the
beginning of their state,
they imagine a set of heroes.
It's sort of happening with people like
George Washington in the United States.
It happens automatically if the founders
of the state,
our state,
our mythologized as of the great heroes
of the past.
It's the great heroes of the past.
Our forefathers who established the
state,
and of course that's true and there were
millions of them,
but you can't tell a story about
millions of people.
So all the actions of those millions of
people are collapsed and condensed and
compressed and turned it into a kind of
fiction that's more real than truth,
that describes the patterns that
characterize how the state was founded
and the Old Testament runs us through
that.
The heroes like Abraham for example,
and Jacob who are crucially involved in
the establishment of the policy of the
actual state,
but something always happens as this
state is established and what happens is
the states established and then people
get off course and the leadership gets
off course and then the state collapses
into a state of chaos,
and then there's a prophetic revelation
warning of that danger,
and then there's a terrible period of
chaotic disruption,
and then there's the regeneration of the
state.
That story is foreshadowed in the Old
Testament by Exodus Moses story.
Egypt's a tyranny.
A leader rises to pull everyone out of
tyranny.
There is a terrible chaotic interlude.
The wandering in the desert,
and then there's the reestablishment of
the state.
That's an archetypal pattern that
happens to all of you.
It happens to every country in the
pattern is here in your system of belief
which is yours in the collective belief
and something arises like a snake and
now it gets to a snake to disrupt it
because the state is insufficiently
adapted to the environment.
It doesn't have all the answers.
It ages and becomes corrupt,
and then it's prone to collapse and that
collapses a catastrophe.
Okay.
Audit catastrophe that happens to you
every time,
for example,
that your dreams are shattered or that
you encounter a great tragedy.
It happens to people when their spouse
dies or when they're diagnosed with a
very,
very dangerous illness or when their
children are damaged.
That event analogous,
as I said to a snake,
and that's partly because the circuits
in your brain that detects snakes that
other animals use to detect snakes are
the same circuits that we use to detect
things that go wrong and things are
always going wrong for us and we're
always collapsing into a state where
we're wandering through a desert and the
desert is a state that's bereft of
meaning and bereft of ideas and in that
state then we're desperately seeking for
while for the establishment of another
state and a state that we hope will be a
better state.
It'll be like the last date,
except there'll be more to it and
everyone will finally be happy and that
that's part of our Utopian dream
and it's impossible not to be in that
story.
You're either in a state of order or
you're in a state of chaos.
That's where the Dallas,
for example,
believed that the world is made out of
order and chaos is because you're always
in one of those two places.
What happens in the old testament is
that the limitations of the state itself
start to become apparent and they become
apparent in that the state has
established,
but it always collapses and then it's
reestablished,
but it always collapses.
It's never permanent,
and and there's repetitions of this
continual repetitions of this and not
out of the Old Testament.
At least the way that it's been
constructed in Christianity is that the
state itself is flawed.
It cannot provide.
The final answer to the question,
what constitutes genuine redemption?
Well,
this is an important issue.
It's an important issue.
Psychologically.
Politically is the state.
The final answer,
well,
it's a totalitarian claim.
We know that it was claimed by people
like Stella.
It was certainly claimed by the
communists.
It was claimed by people like Hitler
that the state was.
The final answer is still claimed in
many ways in places like China.
Today,
the is subsumed underneath the state
organization in this state,
well,
under Schell in the state was already in
a state of perfection.
If you complained about its
imperfection,
then you were going to be killed.
So the idea that the state is perfect,
although it's a tremendously flawed
idea,
can be pursued so hard,
people who are gripping their narrow
viewpoints that the state itself becomes
murderous.
The Old Testament sorta sums itself up
in the book of job and it's a
problematic summing up because joe is
tormented in all sorts of ways.
Everything that could possibly be
terrible that happens to any person
happens to job and he can't understand
why so job is in like a final state of
unredeemed being the states,
not the answer
well,
so then if being is order being is chaos
and chaos is intolerable and the state
order is not the answer,
what do you have left?
That's the question the new testament
attempts to solve.
One of the problems with with the Soviet
Union,
for example,
was their inability to correct errors.
See,
when you start out with an a priori
hypothesis about what constitutes the
truth and that structures your life,
it's very difficult to make the kind of
micro corrections that estate has to
make on a continual basis in order to
remain dynamic and fluid.
So in order to stay adaptive to reality,
not only do you have to have a
viewpoint,
but you have to engage in a process of
modifying that viewpoint and the way
that you engage in the process of
modifying that viewpoint.
There's two ways really.
One is continual minor adjustments as a
consequence of paying attention.
So for example,
if you're having a conversation with
your wife or a friend,
or maybe it's a difficult conversation,
there's a couple of ways that
conversation can go.
One is you can take your viewpoint and
you can impose it on that person,
and often when people are talking,
that's what they're trying to do.
They're not having a conversation.
What they're doing is attempting to
impose a viewpoint that they already
hold the ear on the person that's
listening and if they're a tyrant or a
bully,
they'll do that and pay no attention
whatsoever to the person's response and
in fact,
they'll get irritated and even violent
if the person doesn't accept.
There are a priority.
Framing
is there an alternative?
Mother is an alternative.
The alternative is to pay attention and
to listen on the off chance that the
person that you're talking to might tell
you something you don't know,
but in order to listen,
you have to be already convinced that
the little theory that you're using to
orient yourself in the world isn't good
enough because if it was good enough,
then why would you bother listening?
So you have to be deeply aware of your
own ignorance and that's what humility
means.
Humility means to be deeply aware of
your own ignorance.
It doesn't mean to slink around in and
ashamed manner.
It means to make the presupposition that
you may still have something left to
learn and that this annoying person in
front of you might have something to
teach you if you would just listen and
so you're discussing a problem and a
problem.
Is this a time when the things you think
aren't working?
That's what constitutes a problem.
So we have a little problem and you're
discussing it.
Let's with your wife and she offers you
her opinion and you can brush it off and
in which case your little state stays
intact.
It doesn't move,
it's still made out of stone.
It's pillars and you're still a tyrant
or you can listen.
You can think,
oh,
I see there,
there's a micro correction that I need
to make in one of the peripheral
elements of my belief,
and that's a little painful because it
means you have to let something go,
your your,
your presumption,
and then you have to be a little chaotic
as you adjust to the new information and
then you have to reconstitute yourself,
and what that means interestingly
enough,
is that you have to make a sacrifice.
God likes sacrifices,
especially if they're of the proper kind
and the proper kind of sacrifices,
the one that you made of your micro
belief.
When you're faced with evidence of
error,
and if you make those sorts of micro
sacrifices,
then God stays pleased with you and the
reason for that is that your models of
the world stay up to date.
Now,
one of the things that happened in the
old testament all the time is that
people are making sacrifices to God and
modern people.
They just have no idea what I like.
Why does God want burnt lamb smoke?
It's not obvious to modern people,
but you know you,
your ancestors were stupid.
They were dramatizing something.
They were dramatizing this tremendous
realization,
but no other creature has ever managed,
which is that there are things you can
do to your being that change the nature
of reality and if you do them properly,
you can make reality better.
It's mind boggling and they acted that
out because they didn't really
understand it.
They noticed that if things weren't
going right,
you had to sacrifice something valuable
and that seemed to make God happy.
Well,
it might've been a firstborn calf or
firstborn son for that matter,
for modern people.
It's more like an idea.
You have to sacrifice an idea that you
hold dear in order to progress because
the ideas that you hold dear are exactly
what are making you suffer.
If you're suffering
so you have to sacrifice them and then
you have to let them go,
and the consequences of that is that you
enter into this little period of chaos
and then maybe you pop out of that and
that's a good thing,
and so here's an interesting
observation.
That process of being in the state and
identifying an error and correcting it,
that's a little death and rebirth.
That's like the Phoenix.
The Phoenix dissolved itself into ashes
and then pops back up as a.
As a new bird
in the new testament,
there's this weird idea for that.
You have to identify with a person who
continually dies in his reward or what
does that mean?
It means that the idea that redemption
itself is not the consequences of being
in a state.
It's the consequence of participating in
a process and the process is the
willingness to continually have yourself
sacrificed,
chaotic and then reward,
and that's what keeps things alive.
Now,
in the,
in the passion story,
there are other elements and the
elements are important.
So for example,
the story of Christ is predicated on the
assumption that the person who is making
the ultimate sacrifices performance
another,
a number of acts or undergoes a number
of processes and one is a disciplined
apprenticeship.
So for example,
in order to have some ideas that you can
let go and then reconstitute,
you have to have some ideas.
You can't just be all chaotic and
uninformed and so in the New Testament,
Christ is a master of tradition.
He's a master of the law and you have to
be disciplined.
You have to be a master of something
before you're formed at all.
You have to be imbued with the spirit of
your ancestors will say.
You have to take on that.
That burden.
You see this reflected in popular
culture.
For example,
in the Movie Pinocchio,
at the end of the movie when Pinocchio
is about to become a real boy,
his last challenge is to rescue his
father and he does that and to rescue
the father means to make peace with your
culture and to embody it.
But then not to assume that that's
absolute.
It's a necessary process of discipline.
The next idea that underlies the passion
ideas in the new testament is that the
ultimate sacrifice is the sacrifice of
yourself to God.
Now,
that's a very strange idea and it's a
very,
very sophisticated idea because what
happens in the old testament is there's
the constant sacrificing of something
else.
This requires a different order of
being.
What does it mean to offer yourself up
as a sacrifice to God?
Well
can think of God as an inevitable
representation of the highest possible
value.
That's what monotheistic pursue memory,
presumed God's nameable.
Even the Israelites presumed that garden
wasn't nameable.
It's inevitable,
but it's the ultimate value.
Whatever the ultimate value is,
you don't know what it is,
but you've got to have some idea and the
idea of offering yourself up as a
sacrifice to God is the same thing as
determining that your life will be
guided by unshakable commitment to the
highest good,
and what that means is that it's no
longer your state that's in charger.
It's no longer your ego that's in
charge.
It's not even you that's in charge.
It means that your conversations with
people who are no longer going to be
about convincing them that your
viewpoint is a right.
It means that what your conversation is
going to be about in your speech about
attempting to represent what you believe
to be true in the most concise and clear
possible manner no matter what,
and that's not how people live.
People live in a sense by.
It's like a conniving and the conniving
is a totalitarian,
conniving.
The conniving is an idea that the world
shouldn't be the way that I wanted to
be.
I have a theory about how I want it to
be and I'm going to enforce that theory
and I'm going to be very angry when the
world doesn't respond the way I wanted
to and maybe even be violent as a
consequence of it and I have some sense
of where I'm headed.
I'm headed for wealth for example,
and I'm headed to an advertisement.
So I'm with my wife when I'm 50 on a
tropical beach and that's how I'm going
to be redeemed.
And it's a narrow and totalitarian
viewpoint.
And then I sacrificed everything to that
and it turns out that that's a very bad
idea because things don't turn out the
way I want them to turn out and the
alternative to that,
and this is part of what happens in the
sermon on the mount,
which is very,
very strange document because it
represents a transformation from the
idea that morality is constituted by
adherence to a set of rules to morality
being aimed at something that you might
think about as more of a positive good.
It's not merely not doing what's wrong,
it's something else.
It's sacrificing yourself in the attempt
to make things better and making things
better.
Not by aiming at what's better,
but by telling what's true and assuming
that if you do that,
then what's better will happen.
Whatever that is,
because the thing is you don't know
what's better.
You don't have the capacity to fully
realize what would constitute better.
When we've seen that,
as I said,
over and over in the 20th century,
people aim at a circumscribed definition
of what constitutes the Utopian state
and all we get out of that is endless.
Hell,
we have to pursue what's good,
but we don't know what's what.
What's good is,
so how do we,
how do we remove ourselves from that
paradox?
Well,
it isn't a matter of gathering more
knowledge.
It's a matter of approaching reality in
a different manner and it is an act of
faith,
his character guard point to code
because if you decide for example that
you're going to pursue the highest good,
whatever that is and the highest good,
pursuing the highest good means.
Being willing to transform what your
conception of the highest good is.
You pursue the highest good.
That's your aim.
Your aim determines the world you live
in.
We know that that's a fact.
That's a psychological fact.
What you aim at determines the nature of
your world and to aim wrong.
That's hard.
Markia by the way,
that's a great word to a wrong that sin,
because Hamartia,
which is an archery term,
which means to miss the target is what
sin means.
So if you're a not in a state of grace,
it means your age wrong.
Naming it the right thing,
or maybe the world is constituted badly
and it's hell bent on torturing you.
That's the alternative viewpoint.
You got to get your aim right.
You name it the best,
and how do you aim?
Well,
the sermon on the mount says something
very interesting.
It says,
okay,
what?
You get your aim right and you decided
to tell the truth.
Then all you have to do is concentrate
on the day.
Now people read the sermon on the mount.
It's a hippy document.
You know,
be like a flower and be like a bird.
Don't pay any attention to the future.
You know everything will be taken care
of.
It's not that at all.
There's presumptions that are nested in
there and the presumption is,
first of all,
that you're aiming at at perfection.
You're aiming at whatever perfection is
and you're not trying to get other
people to do that.
You're aiming at it.
You're reconstituting your actions and
your speech to aim at that,
and then you do that by noticing very
carefully and attending to what
constitutes the truth,
and then you let that take you wherever
it will go.
And that's the sacrifice of self to God
because you the truth is a
representation of whatever constitutes
reality,
your best attempt at whatever
constitutes reality and to follow that
leans to follow something that's
transcendent because whatever reality
is,
it's certainly not something that you're
individually responsible for creating,
even though you might participate in
that process to speak.
The truth is to be guided by being.
It's a completely different motive being
now I said right after Adam and Eve's
catastrophic emergence into self
consciousness,
the world split into two attitudes,
one associated with pain and the other
associated with Abel can that those
attitudes are associated with heaven and
hell.
Well,
we know that human beings can turn the
world into help.
If you're a student of history,
you have no doubt about that and no
matter how terrible you think the hell
that people have created in the past is
if you read a little more history,
you will find something even more
terrible.
And people of course are afraid of the
human capacity to turn things into hell.
That that's one of the things that
underlies our environmental,
isn't.
We're afraid that our misbehavior will
turn the world into help,
will be,
we believe we can do that.
Do we believe that human beings can turn
the world into heaven?
Well,
that's a harder thing to believe it
because there's a lot more ways that
things could go wrong.
Then there are ways that things can go
right,
so heaven's a much narrower thing to a
map than hell,
which is a chaotic mess.
Well,
maybe it's improbable,
but life is improbable.
That's for sure,
and our unredeemed state of being is
improbable and the other that's
improbable is the burden that we're
required to carry.
Existentially,
we're,
we're awake creatures of God.
What does that mean?
Oh,
that we suffer and it's real that
suffering,
and it's not only that we suffer in that
we feel pain,
which is bad enough in frustration and
disappointment and all of the
catastrophic things that are associated
with life,
but even worse,
we can apprehend the possibility of that
recurring in the future.
So even when none of those terrible
things happen to be happening right now,
it's pretty easy for us to imagine that
they're going to happen tomorrow and
they will.
So not only can we imagine that they're
going to happen again tomorrow,
they are going to happen again tomorrow.
So we're in a state of constant
unredeemed suffering.
It's a big problem.
And you know,
if you think about,
you can't even imagine a state that
would address that.
It's just too big a problem.
Well,
so then there's another inference in the
new testament and it's hypothesis of a
metta state,
and the inference is that a life that's
predicated on constant death and renewal
at every level of being a life that's
predicated on a search for the truth
and,
and an attempt to act out the truth and
our life that's associated with the
sacrifice of self to God produces a
state of being that so deeply meaningful
that it justifies suffering,
doesn't eliminate suffering.
There's no elimination of suffering.
Nisha said he hasn't.
He who has a why can bear any how and
what he meant by that was if what you're
aiming at is of sufficient profundity,
it's worth an awful lot of misery to
participate in the process of bringing
it about and life has an unbearable
depth of misery and as a consequence it
needs a and observe positive aim and the
observed positive aim.
It's positive in the new testament.
It is participation in the process that
transforms earth into heaven,
the generation of the Kingdom of God on
earth,
and that actually means something.
It means that the state of being that is
described by the parameters that I
already laid out,
the willingness to engage in Inter
eternal sacrificial death and renewal
and sacrifice of the self to the highest
value produces a state of being
subjectively that's associated with
habitation in the Kingdom of God and the
actions that are conducted in that state
are what?
Transform the interpersonal state into
the political state.
That's a manifestation of that kingdom.
Now you all know this.
You know this the same way that the
people who wrote the Bible know what,
because of course people just like you
wrote the Bible in the Bible is about
people.
When you have a deeply meaningful
conversation with someone,
you change them and you change yourself.
You know that and the process that
you're engaged in,
while you have that deeply meaningful
conversation,
that's a mode of being and that motive
being to the degree that that have
motive being is predicated on the
attempt to communicate as truthfully as
possible and with the highest possible
end in mind.
Then right then and there,
you're in that state.
Now you can tell when you're in that
state because number one,
you're not self conscious.
Time disappears.
Number two,
what you're engaged in is deeply
meaningful.
You don't bear the tragic burden of your
life at that moment because what's
happening with you is so worthwhile that
it consumes you completely and people
are in that state to a widely varying
degree,
but everyone is in it.
Sometimes when something like that
happens to you,
especially once you learn to notice it,
you think
while there's nothing better than that,
and if there's nothing better than that,
then you might ask yourself,
why do anything else now?
I've tried to figure that out.
I've tried to figure that out for years.
It's like,
because to me,
these look like existential realities.
They're not hypothetical states.
They're not shoved off into some
transcendent heaven.
They're not other worldly.
They're part of being itself.
People can enter states of heaven and
hell and they can learn to stay longer
in one state or another,
so why don't they stay in the best
possible state?
Well,
one problem is the commitment of faith.
I think it's very terrifying to let go
of the direction of your life and say,
well,
I'm going to go wherever the attempt to
speak the truth will pick me because God
only knows where you're going to end up
and it's certainly not where you think.
In fact,
the willingness to abandoned going to
where you think is a prerequisite for
doing this,
and so in a sense you're.
You're a ship that the wind takes
wherever it wants to take,
and the second problem I think is that
it's a real responsibility because in
order to undertake this process,
you have to come to terms with the idea
that what you do in your life,
you're wretched,
miserable,
tragic prone life actually matters.
Really it matters.
You know when people complain about
meaninglessness in their life all the
time,
but I think that's,
that's a kind of face saving illusion.
I think people are more afraid of
meaning than they are of meaninglessness
because of meaningless means.
Meaninglessness means,
well,
I can do whatever I want.
I mean it might be kind of second rate
and might be dull.
It might be dangerous,
it might be destructive,
but it doesn't matter.
So I can do whatever I want.
I have no responsibility because I don't
mean anything,
so I'm not responsible to anything or
anyone.
But if your life actually has meaning
and it doesn't always have meaning,
it has meaning.
When you're doing something that's
meaningful,
well then all of a sudden you are
responsible to a higher power,
so to speak.
You're responsible to your own soul and
you're responsible to the state of being
that characterizes the world itself,
and that's a massive,
massive responsibility.
It's to take responsibility in a sense.
It's to take responsibility for the sins
of the world,
which is another prerequisite of the
motive being that's described in the new
testaments,
a very strange idea.
The redeemer takes on the sins of the
world.
What does that mean?
Well,
it means,
oh,
human beings are Nazis and human beings
are the red garden.
Human beings are the slaughterers in
Rwanda and we're all human beings,
and so to take on the sins of the world
means to realize that all those things
that characterize the human capacity to
turn the earth into hell characterize
you,
and then in order to live properly,
you have to live in a manner that
addresses those elements of your nature.
And again,
that's it.
That's a terrible responsibility.
Well,
first of all,
who wants to admit that?
Second of all,
who can stand looking at it and third,
who's going to take on the burden of
solving it?
Well,
it better be all of us or we're just
going to keep doing it.
So redemption,
what?
What does it mean?
It means we're not in a state of grace.
Why?
We're self conscious.
We're aware of the owner of the tragedy
of our being.
We're unwilling to take full
responsibility for it or were ignorant
about how to do that and that leaves us
bereft.
How do we solve that?
Well,
we can solve it with a estate,
but the problem is the state is not
reliable.
It degenerated into tyranny.
Then it transforms into chaos.
Then it reconstitutes itself and does
the same thing again.
It's not a good answer.
Is there another answer?
Well,
maybe.
I believe that what is outlined in
narrative form in the new testament is
psychologically correct.
I believe that the idea that endless
micro death and renewal produces a state
of proper ad outpatient to being and
that the prerequisites for that that are
laid out in the narrative structure that
underlies the new testament are
fundamentally correct.
So to be redeemed is to aim at the
highest value,
to sacrifice what's no longer useful and
valid in yourself and to tell the truth
and the consequence of that is existence
in a deep state of meaning that
justifies the tragedy of being and the
possibility of transforming your own
life in the most beneficial,
positive direction while simultaneously
doing that for the people around you.
And that's redemption.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Support Ontario's public television.
Donate at [inaudible] dot org.